معنا من رام الله الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه نهاد ابو غوش اذا الانتقادات
لنتنياهو تزداد حده كل يوم والخلافات
تتفاقم والانتقادات هذه الان من ايزنكوت
ليس فقط من المعارضه هذا عضو في مجلس
الحرب الى ماذا يؤشر
ذلك صباح الخير نعم هي الانتقادات تاتي
نتنياهو من كل حذب وصوب من داخل الائتلاف
الحكومي ومن داخل مجلس الحرب من المجتمع
من المعارضه من كتاب الراي من الولايات
المتحده وايضا من حتى اقرب حلفاء
نتنياهو داخل الحكومه وداخل مجلس الحرب كل
هذه الانتقادات تؤكد على مساله رئيسيه ان
اسرائيل لم تحقق اهداف الحرب التي اعلنها
نتنياهو خلال الايام الثلاث الماضيه رصدنا
جميع المقالات الوارده في الصحف
الاسرائيليه اكثر من نصف المقالات
تتحدث عن ضروره ابرام صفقه شامله مع
المقاومه تؤدي الى اطلاق حتى لو ادت الى
اطلاق جميع الاسرار الفلسطينيين مقابل
عوده الاسرى كل المقالات تؤكد على ضروره
عوده الاسرى وتؤكد في نفس الوقت استحاله
استعاده اي اسير على قيد الحياه بهذه
الطريقه التي يصر عليها نتنياهو وهي
مواصله الضغط على قطع غزه على حماس على
المقاومه على الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل عام
ويؤكدون ان هذا لن يحرر اي اير على
الاطلاق حتى ان احد رؤساء الاركان
السابقين في اسرائيل اسمه دان حلوتس قال
ان الانتصار الحقيقي لاسرائيل في هذه
الحرب هي الخلاص من نتنياهو والاطاحه به
ولذلك فعلا كل المؤشرات كل الاستطلاعات
تؤشر على تراجع شعبيه
نتنياهو انعدام اي فرصه لتحقيق الاهداف
التي يدعو لها والشيء الوحيد الذي يؤكده
المعلقون والسياسيون ان نتنياهو يخوض حربه
الخاصه من اجل البقاء بالسلطه هوي يغامر
باسرائيل كلها يغامر بالجنود يغامر بمصير
الاسرى يغامر بكل شيء من اجل البقاء في
السلطه لان لو توقف القتال يوما واحدا فقط
فسوف ينفك عنه او ينفض عنه حلفائه
اليمنيون ويسقطون الحكومه اذا كانت كل هذه
الضغوط من كل هذه الجهات على نتنياهو بما
فيها ايضا الاداره الامريكيه ونتحدث الان
عن توبيخ من اداره بايدن بسبب ارتفاع عدد
القتلى المدنيين على ماذا وع من يراهن
نتنياهو حتى يبقى متمسكا بمنصبه ويخرج بكل
ثقه ليقول ان الحرب مستمره مهما كلفت
ثمام هو يزعم ان معه تفويض من الشعب لانه
منتخب ولديه اغلبيه في الكنيست 64 مقعد كل
رهانه على انه اخذ تفويضا لاربع سنوات لكن
هذا التفويض هو الان يمثل اغلبيه لكن
استمرار هذه الحرب واستمرار هذه الضغوط
على الاغلب انه سوف يؤدي الى تصدع ائتلافه
الحكومي وربما خروج بعض قاده اللكود من
اللكود يعني هناك حديث عن انه كل من مثلا
يوف جلنت وزير الدفاع بالاضافه عضوي
الكنيست نير بركات
و يولي ادلشتاين الذي كان رئيس سابق
للكنيست حتى بعض الاحزاب الدينيه المتزمت
مثل حزب شاس برئاسه اريا درعي يفكرون في
الخروج من هذه الحكومه او الضغط يعني
مشاركه المعارضه في ضغطها على نتنياهو لان
نتنياهو يورط كل الدوله هو يعتقد ان معه
تفويضا كاملا هذا منجاه وهو يراهن ايضا
على انه يمكن ان يحقق معجزه ما البعض شبه
نتنياهو
بالمقامرة قدات تاتيه حتى من قياده الجيش
خصوصا ان رئيس الاركان هيرتس ليفي قال ان
الانجازات التي حققتها اسرائيل خلال
الشهور الماضيه بدات ت تتاكل بسبب عدم
تحديد وايضاح اهداف الحرب اهداف الحرب ما
زالت غائمه غير واضحه وليس هناك اي وحده
عليها خصوصا الادعاء بالقضاء على حماس
شكرا لك نهاد ابوغوش الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه كنت معنا من رام الله شكرا
جزيلا لك